انضم الينا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد ما نقلته شبكه ان بي سي
بخصوص الخلافات التي خلفتها زيارات او
زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن الى اسرائيل مؤخرا ما الذي يتداول
بخصوصها
اسرائيليا هذه حقي حقيقه منذ بدايه الحرب
ومنذ ان كان الرئيس الامريكي بايدن قد زار
اسرائيل في بدايه الحرب وسال نتنياهو س
بهذا الخصوص وماذا ستفعلون في اليوم
التالي ولم يكن لدى نتنياهو رد على ذلك
وطلب منه ان يكون رؤيه لكن نتنياهو منذ
ذلك الحين ونحن في اليوم ال 104 لهذه
الحرب يتهرب لانه يعرف ان هذه القضيه
ستخلق صداما له مع حلفائه من اليمين
العنصري سموتريتش وبن جفير لذلك ما اوردته
القناه الامريكيه هو يتردد هنا وتعكسه
ايضا حاله التخ ط السياسيه داخل دوائر صنع
القرار في اسرائيل التي سجلت ذروه جديده
خلال الاسبوعين الاخيرين بال التهجمات
الموجهه حسب الكثير من الاسرائيليين موجهه
بايعاز من نتنياهو التي استهدفت اولا رئيس
هيئه الاركان قبل اكثر من عشره ايام ومن
ثم استهدفت وزير الدفاع جلنت واستهدفت
ايضا الوزير في مجلس الحرب زعيم معسكر
الدوله بن جانز لذلك يرون بان نتنياهو
انما يحاول ان يحافظ على وضعه كرئيس
للحكومه الاسرائيليه وما اوردته القناه
الامريكيه يتحدث عن اليوم التالي لزوال
نتنياهو او انتهاء ولاياته كرئيس للحكومه
هو ياتي في اطار التمنيات لان نتنياهو
لديه قاعده ائتلافيه من 64 مقعدا هي
اغلبيه مقاعد الكنيست ال 120 ونتنياهو
وجميع حلفائه من الاحزاب
المتطرفه
مثل عظمه يهوديه والصهيونيه الدينيه وايضا
المتدينين المتشددين والليكود يدركون جيدا
ان انهيار الحكومه حاليا سيقود الى
انتخابات واجراء انتخابات فانهم سيفقدون
الكثير من قوتهم في ظل ما تشير اليه
استطلاعات الراي من ناحيه وحالتهم المزريه
شعبيا بسبب ان هناك فشل ذريع سواء في
السابع من اكتوبر او خلال اداره هذه الحرب
وهناك قناعه متزايده في الشارع الاسرائيلي
من ان نتنياهو كل ما يفعله الان انه يضع
مصلحته الحزبيه ومكاسبه السياسيه الشخصيه
كي يبقى رئيسا للحكومه من خلال تثبيت
توليفته هو اهمه الاول والاخير وهو ما
يشير الى انه وحلفائه سيستمرون على راس
هذه الحكومه حتى نهايه ولايتها اللهم الا
اذا كان هناك انشقاقات من داخل حزب الليكو
تحديدا الذي يتزعمه نتنياهو والاصابع تؤشر
الى وزير الدفاع جلنت وربما ثلاثه او
اربعه اخرين اذا اذا توفر ذلك فان نتنياهو
سيسقط لكن اذا لم يتوفر فان حكومه نتنياهو
ونتنياهو كرئيس للوزراء سيستمر الولايات
المتحده ربما تحاول ان تلمح لنتنياهو بان
عليه ان يعدل من موقفه وكان ذلك قد سبق
وصول بلينكن الاسبوع الماضي عندما او قبل
الماضي عندما جاء الى اسرائيل سبقته
معلومات تقول بان الولايات المتحده بعثت
بتلميحات لنتنياهو ان عليه ان يختار اما
ان ينحاز ل سموتريتش وبن كفير ومواقفهم
معروفه او ان يحافظ او هكذا جاء او ان
يحافظ على الدعم الامريكي له في هذه الحرب
بمعنى ان ينحاز لمواقف جانس وجلن وايضا
الولايات المتحده هذا الوضع في اسرائيل
يعكس حاله التخبط في السياسيه وهي ايضا
انعكاس لحاله التخبط العسكريه في الميدان
في قطاع غزه فالميدان ايضا رغم ان السد
تتحدث عن ان قواتها تتقدم وتقاتل فوق
الارض وتحت الارض لكن واضح للاسرائيليين
وعلى كافه المستويات ان جيشهم حتى الان لم
يحقق تقدما استراتيجيا نحو الاهداف التي
يعلنها وان كل ما جرى حتى الان بعد منذ
السابع من اكتوبر حتى هذه الساعه هو
المزيد من القتل والمزيد من الدمار فهو لم
يتقدم نحو ما يصفه نتنياهو باباده حماس او
نزع قدراتها السلطويه والعسكريه ولم ولم
يتقدم نحو النجاح في اعاده او تحرير اسرى
اسرائيليين محتجزين في قطاع غزه كما ان
رفض سكان غلاف غزه العوده الى بلداتهم
التي نزحوا عنها منذ بدايه الحرب يشير الى
ان ليس هناك قناعه بان كل هذه الحرب
الضاريه الداميه قد حققت لهم الشعور
بالامن كي يعودوا الى هذه المناطق هذا
بمجمله يشير الى ان نتنياهو انما يصعد من
تصريحاته ويحاول الحفاظ على وتيرتها منذ
البدايه لارضاء حلفائه في اليمين المتطرف
كي يبقوا معه في هذه التوليفه ولتثبيت
ائتلافه الولايات المتحده من ناحيتها
عندما ارسلت وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
بلينكن في رابع او خامس زياره له مؤخرا
كانت تحاول ان تقنع نتنياهو بضروره ان
يتحول في هذا الموقف وان يحاول جذب اطراف
اخرى او احزاب اخرى مثل يوجد مستقبل التي
يقودها يائير لبيد ليكون الى جانب جانس
وجنت وغيرهم لكن نتنياهو لا يفعل ذلك ولا
يريد ذلك لان الائتلاف الحالي هو ائتلافه
الذي صنعه بيده وليد العمري مدير مكتبنا
من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك ok